seguindo a tradição hoje do evento foi
então em dezembro de 2004
mais especificamente o dia 26 de
dezembro um dia depois do natal teve um
terremoto de 9 pontos sudeste asiático
seguido de um tsunami que deixou 230 mil
pessoas mortas em 14 países diferentes
devastou cidades inteiras na tailândia
indonésia e odor por completo a vida de
milhões de pessoas nesse lugar
mas nossa vida também mudou um pouco
depois desde se dessa catástrofe natural
e é por isso que a gente hoje está aqui
com você
desde a infância e tem mais duas pessoas
que estão aqui hoje somos amigos no
mesmo bairro foi contra mas vejam praia
no rio de janeiro ea gente surfa né
são três semanas antes de deter essa
taxa fica no sudeste asiático
eu estava na ilha de sumatra e banda
tinha muito próximo a onde foi o
epicentro e quando teve aquilo tudo que
a gente acompanhou pela televisão a
gente começou a ficar angustiado e mais
até porque a gente chegava os números de
mortes em banda tia que era em torno de
200 mil mortos ea mídia só falava da
tailândia porque é um lugar turístico e
60 então a gente já tinha uma viagem
programada pra voltar pra lá pra surfar
na indonésia a gente resolveu sem
qualquer tipo de experiência sou
economista não foi um frango na época
ela publicitário tinha mais um outro
economista e mais um advogado sem
qualquer experiência a gente resolveu
transformar uma viagem que será uma
viagem de surgir um documentário do
centro do tsunami no centro do terremoto
esse documentário a gente fez uma só
aprenderá toda essa técnica de filmagem
e edição e demorou um ano para ficar
pronto é esse documentário acabou
participando de alguns festivais
internacionais e foi bem aceito pela
crítica passou no sport tv
é um absurdo ainda passa no canal brasil
e alguns cinemas daqui do brasil ea
gente sempre com aquela idéia de voltar
pra algum lugar problemática e fazer um
outro documentário
só que isso a gente tá falando já em
torno de 1 2006 2007 e um mundo estava
um pouco mudando a partir de milho a tv
a cabo estava começando a crescer mais
específica melhor de canais e foi nesse
momento que a gente teve a idéia de
transformar toda a pegada daquele
documentário a gente tinha feito e botar
um programa de tv
foi o que a gente fez a gente modelo uma
ideia já com a nossa experiência do
documentário e fazer um programa de tv
para tv a cabo porque a gente entende
que com um programa de tv as coisas
seriam muito mais dinâmicas mais
rapidamente a gente poder abordar causas
muito né a causa diferente e muito mais
causa do que simplesmente um
documentário e agora voltei pra fazer a
gente com essa proposta baixo do braço
foi um show apresentou isso pra eles
eles toparam e pedir pra gente fazer um
piloto na época a gente não sabe nem que
era piloto não entendia isso muito bem
e aí o agente conversando com eles eles
falaram à gostei mas ele tem que por
conta própria gente acabou indo pra
minha mãe é o país do sudeste asiático
que vive sob ditadura militar até hoje e
31 voltou com quatro episódios de la
rosa gostou do que a gente apresentou e
desde então a gente já tá esse ano a
gente vai fazer a oitava temporada no
multishow gente passou por países com
minha marina irá acolher do norte
somália ucrânia japão pós tsunami e onde
teve um problema do mundo hoje que a
gente tentou abordar aí sempre
respeitando o mínimo de segurança às
vezes a gente errou mas a gente tentou
ao longo dessas oito temporadas
dessas sete temporadas passar um pouco
das nossas divisões divisão de quatro
amigos viajando para lugares
problemáticos sem aquela cara de um
programa jornalístico
acho que o felipe com também essa
história até o nascimento não conta lá
em casa em um resuminho porque não dá
pra gente ficar aqui 40 horas na gente
tem 18 minutos não ficaria 18 minutos
vezes
sem contando cada lugar que a gente foi
cada história que a gente conheceu mais
um pouco dos bastidores do programa em
si do conceito que a gente quis criar o
programa passa por isso que ele contou
nós somos quatro amigos agora três na
frente do programa com um desejo que a
gente tinha de conhecer algumas das
grandes histórias da humanidade de
entrar em contato direto com algumas das
grandes causas da humanidade e não
existia até então no formato que a gente
queria traduzir se bem organicamente não
existe um formato desses na televisão é
hoje em dia muita gente pergunta se
nosso documentário se nosso programa é
um documentário é jornalismo se é
reality show e na verdade ele não é nada
disso e ao mesmo tempo e tudo isso então
é pra ser uma coisa orgânica natural
super aberta aos imprevistos nós
viajamos como quatro amigos não tem
equipe segurança é pessoal fazendo um
som áudio 7 tal é sobre tal somos quatro
amigos querendo conhecer de verdade
alguns dos das situações dos das
culturas das histórias que a gente
sempre teve curiosidade e inclusive a
gente não viaja com visto de jornalista
a gente mente nas migrações países mundo
afora
eu não sei porque infelizmente a gente
mente recentemente as migrações mandar
fora e falando que estamos indo fazer
turismo porque a gente não quer filtro
nenhum naquela história que a gente está
querendo contar a gente não quer ser
recebido por um representante do governo
a gente não quer é um carro oficial que
vai colocar a gente no hotel especial
não a gente quer contato direto com a
conheça essas situações com essas
histórias ea gente pode contar que
alguns episódios em alguns algumas cenas
pitorescas assim que acontecer em
algumas dessas viagens e que ilustram
bem alguns pontos chave que a gente
gosta de colocar como sendo o conceito
do programa
um deles é que a gente acreditava muito
que a gente o público presente público
jovem porque a gente fala brasileiro é
que ele queria assim notícias sobre
cultura sobre política geografia
história mas ele um público criado na
velocidade do videoclipe na era da
internet não queria mais aquela versão é
meio careta do jornalista durão com o
microfone na mão totalmente distante do
objeto daquilo que ele estava
portanto ele queria uma coisa mais
verdadeira de uma galera jovem dupla
fazendo perguntas é que eram realmente
da curiosidade pessoal delas é isso que
a gente se propôs a fazer em um ano por
exemplo uma história que conta um pouco
isso aconteceu na coréia do norte
a gente visitou a coreia do norte que
muita gente disse que era impenetrável
que a gente não ia fazer um programa de
tv dentro da coreia do norte e realmente
viajar para a coreia do norte uma coisa
completamente surreal é você consegue
viajar é difícil tirar um visto de
turista mas não tão difícil assim e você
viaja em total segurança
mas o tempo todo você acompanhado por
dois guias oficiais do governo norte
coreano
eles vão para onde você for eles
estabelecem qual o roteiro você vai
seguir ficam hospedados no mesmo hotel
que você tá você não dá um passo no
lobby sentar com a presença desses dois
levando para um lugar para o outro ea
gente visitava universidades e palácios
e prédios do governo parece aquela coisa
super ensaiado a gente entrava em uma
sala e tava as crianças lá tirando 10
matemática a entrar numa sala de música
e determinado momento tinha de ser lá
1520 criancinha nós colhemos tocando
assim joão virtuose perfeito fazendo os
acordes e como a gente falou somos
quatro amigos viajando juntos não
perdemos a chance de poder colocar outra
situação embora sozinho franco agora vai
fazer uma dança pra você que não é
verdade mas na casa na coréia do norte a
gente pegou o léo que é um dos amigos
que apresenta o programa a gente toca um
pouco de violão e até determinada a
apresentação das crianças norte coreanas
sente pela gente léo quer tocar uma
modinha da nossa terra pra vocês eu não
não é isso que a gente não faz desfeita
vai lá toca alguma coisa e ele tocou
rock roll e tocou aquela música de joni
bigoo um dos clássicos do rock'n'roll
néné
como é que é já sei que pegaram a idéia
e ele começou a tocar essa música e as
crianças tentando imitar os acordes
assim a nossa guia uma dessas guias que
eu falei que acompanhava a gente o tempo
todo olhando embevecido assim pra ele
era uma guia de 27 anos uma menina
inteligente cima jovem interessada fala
inglês fluentemente perguntou pra no
final da apresentação do léo é o que
você tocou pra gente e eu toquei um
rock'n'roll ela você tocou
roque roque roque roque ela não conhece
essa expressão rock'n'roll nunca ouvi
falar nisso e eu levo até na ocasião de
ônibus é uma música que é tocada naquele
filme clássico de volta para o futuro
ele toca ele volta ele vem do futuro
toca as pessoas no passado eo léo
espirituoso na hora deu a resposta igual
que o personagem do filme ele falou é
vocês não conhecem isso mas quem sabe o
filho de vocês vai gostar muito ou não a
gente nunca vai saber até agora não
gostei agora não conhecer mas são
histórias como essa que acabam
ilustrando aqueles conceitos histórias e
fatos que a gente estava acostumado a
ver nos livros de história no colégio ou
no jornal que a gente lê diariamente ou
na televisão
só que eles deixam de ser fatos e acaba
sendo uma coisa muito mais tangível
porque é através de pessoas de histórias
situações foram contou um pouco da
coreia do norte nem qual a coreia do
norte fez parte da nossa primeira
temporada acho que a primeira temporada
não conta lá em casa foi muito fácil de
determinar o destino em 2009 o george
bush ainda era presidente dos estados
unidos e de repente ele taxou cinco
países do planeta como países do eixo do
mal
o motivo seja quando políticos são os
países do eixo do mal
e olha que não conta nem casas e na
mesma maneira que o doc surgiu a partir
de um questionamento de porque a mídia
não mostrava a banda já se mostrava
tailândia a gente poupa os cinco
primeiros destinos aí porque será que só
os países país são e se faz para fazer
parte do eixo do mal
então a gente foi pra mianmar coréia do
norte e irã e iraque e afeganistão
afeganistão gente na primeira temporada
acabou ficando muito em cima era o
momento de eleição no afeganistão e
aconselharam a gente aí um ano seguinte
a gente acabou fazendo no afeganistão a
segunda temporada
eu queria falar com isso é porque o
nessa primeira temporada a gente pode
ver dois exemplos totalmente antagônicos
de situações que a mídia passa pra você
de uma maneira errada
o primeiro exemplo o irã a gente foi
para o irá
mil e cem 2009 tinha acabado de ter
reeleição do ahmadineja ea mídia passava
o verão como lugar e ditador é homens
bombas é a radicais islâmicos ea gente
mesmo fazendo uma consulta sabendo que
não era tudo isso que a mídia passado a
gente é entendendo o irã de uma outra
maneira quando a gente chegou na herança
de a gente se deparou com era totalmente
diferente do que a mídia passava era o
irã superamigo pacífico seguro as
pessoas paravam na rua com um dia que a
gente era estrangeiro e queriam dar
carona queriam levar gente pra comer na
casa delas e até mesmo a questão da
relação da mulher no irã que existe
alguma coisa ali da questão da mulher no
irã não estou dizendo que isso é uma
invenção mas ela recebe uma outra
conotação que porque quando chegou no
irã onde acabou conhecendo três meninos
iranianos que mostraram a cidade pra
gente levar a gente para o museu isso
foi tratado super uma forma normal pela
população as pessoas passavam riam sabe
não tinha nenhum tipo de estresse é um
nada relacionado a isso a gente até teve
uma boa situação e acho que a parte
desse preconceito é que a gente tenta
evitar de pronto quando a gente vai para
os lugares que a gente vai fazer uma
viagem é de oito horas de noite por uma
estrada no meio do irã e o cara passando
as instruções para a gente a respeito
dessa estrada na primeira pergunta foi
bom essa estrada segura
ele não entendeu perguntei você como
assim segurança no irã é pra ele era
tipo eu tenho qualquer tipo de problema
de segurança aqui está no irã na e eu
falei caramba tinha ainda mesmo tentando
não vim com preconceitos a gente acaba
chegando com algum tipo de preconceito e
oposto a isso foi a nossa experiência do
iraque
a gente foi para o iraque no mesmo ano
2009 a agosto de 2009
a gente tinha acabado de ir pra me amar
coreia do norte irã então a gente falou
pavão concluirá que agora a gente tinha
ganho um pouco de confiança nessas
viagens sem dar tudo certo ea nas nossas
pesquisas de pré-produção a gente
começou a identificar algumas opiniões
diferentes sobre a situação do iraque
néel estados unidos acaba de sair de
bagdá em maio de 2009 e estava passando
mídia que a situação no iraque bagdá
estava resolvida
não agora é tranquilo vocês virem para o
iraque está segura e certa a gente
entrou em contato com a embaixada do
iraque em brasília e ele fala não
realmente agora já está começando a dar
visto de turismo a gente o papo beleza
que a gente vai fazer turismo naquela
parte do meio do agente david turista
porque legal quanto os turistas
brasileiros já foram fluindo vocês por
ele
vocês são os primeiros a gente acabou
indo é um pouco dessa auto confiança que
a gente ganhou nos outros lugares quando
a gente chegou no iraque a situação era
muito pior do que o nosso pior pesadelo
a gente encontrou um país totalmente
guerra que não tinha segurança não tinha
vida no iraque era uma situação que do
aeroporto até o nosso hotel que o hotel
que a gente ficou foram 16 check point
assim eram 20 km 16 check point
o carro que foi pegar gente no aeroporto
tipo aquelas mercedes bem antiga da
década de 80 branca parecia um filme que
o buraco de buraco assim na frente né e
o caso o motorista se não você que
parece um pouco aquilo vai na frente por
ano e já está em casa né
botou fran na janelinha também perto
alertou isso aqui passa também olhei
aquele buraco olhei pro carro o
motorista se ele fala pouco inglês
eu fiz assim para ele de repente tipo
raio vai cair duas vezes no mesmo lugar
então porque lembrou pato tranquilos se
verei atrás então mas não irá que a
gente encontra uma situação totalmente
caótica de pra ficar uma semana no
iraque ea gente ficou três dias a gente
quis voltar num bom seguinte o próprio
aeroporto a gente pousou focará tá tudo
errado aqui dá pra voltar quando ele foi
ver o avião já tinha descolado tinha
mais ninguém no iraque ea gente acabou
ficando três dias só eu próprio hotel
que a gente ficou que a gente achava que
era um lugar seguro
dois meses depois explodiu um caminhão
bomba morreu todo mundo o teu senhor é
hoje o que ficou arrepiado só de lembrar
dessa história e aí eu seja um pouco de
aviso até pra gente assim do que a gente
não repórter de guerra a gente sempre
teve essa percepção
começou a fazer o programa porque eu
acho que a gente quando um repórter de
guerra tem sua função óbvio é relatar
uma guerra
só que a gente queria um programa um
pouco diferente disso a gente quer
abordar as questões mais profundas em
uma guerra todo mundo tão louco todo
mundo fora da razão que ninguém consegue
abordar direito as coisas nesses lugares
como deveria ser então a gente se aquilo
seja um pouco de alerta então a gente
começou a selecionar lugares e momentos
para ir a esses lugares estão com isso
que aconteceu pouco relacionado ao
afeganistão é outro ponto também a gente
eu falei um pouco sobre a questão do
formato falou da importância da gente
questionar as informações que chegam até
gente que são alguns dos fatores que
passam pela pela história do programa e
outra dessas super importantes questões
é de que o mundo não é preto e branco
sabe isso é uma coisa que a gente em
casa você tem uma coisa que é um link
entre praticamente todos os destinos que
a gente visitou com o programa é de que
o mundo não é preto e branco e eu me
lembro bem disso porque estudando na
época da faculdade tinham naquela época
você também na conformado e tal aí tinha
dois livros que eu estudava falou que
nunca vou usar isso na minha vida porque
estou perdendo meu tempo já na praia do
que estudando e lembrando que um deles
falava sobre etnocentristas e outro
sobre relativismo cultural e hoje os
conceitos que estava ali passa
basicamente pela unção lemas de vida pra
mim e traduzindo resumindo bastante eles
falam sobre é você não conseguiu não
poder julgar a cultura do outro com base
nos valores da sua cultura é o que é bom
ou mau o que é certo ou errado que é
ruim ou bom
variam que é bom pra mim pode ser ruim
para o outro é ruim para o outro pode
ser bom pra mim
então é muito difícil a gente conseguir
colocar numa balança ou tentar julgar
culturas diferentes
e pra finalizar que a gente está
estourando tempo aqui é eu acho que a
gente consegue o objetivo talvez final
assim de tudo que a gente contou aqui é
e como vocês viram de uma forma super
informal tanto na palestra como no
programa
apesar de ter um pensamento por trás uma
coisa muito orgânica ea gente tem o
desejo de ser um exemplo mas da forma
mais humilde possível porque pode
parecer um pouco de arrogância
a gente quer ser um exemplo mas acho que
é justamente o contrário é um exemplo da
forma mais humilde possível de as
pessoas verem que quatro amigos sem
experiência em televisão sem contatos
maiores conseguiram hoje podem falar que
a gente entrevistou terrorista
entrevistou chefe de estado entrevistou
o prêmio nobel da paz com isso participa
de missão da onu
levamos o pastor de uma expedição de
ajuda humanitária no japão logo depois
do tsunami então espero que as pessoas
olhem pra gente para encarar esses caras
conseguiram a gente também pode ea gente
acredita que por trás disso tudo tem a
função social do programa é mais do que
a gente podia falar que mais do que um
projeto de trabalho é um projeto de vida
a gente acredita que a gente tem sim
obrigação de tentar fazer desse mundo um
mundo melhor
claro que o programa foi a ferramenta
mais adequada que a gente achou você
pode escrever um livro para escrever um
blog fazer uma rádio comunitária fazer
trabalho voluntário ou se um médico um
advogado que quer que seja o engenheiro
e da sua contribuição social e essa só o
grãozinho de areia que a gente está
tentando fazer diferença mas a gente
também acredita que de repente
degrauzinho de areia um grãozinho de
areia a gente consegue mudar o mundo
a isso obrigado agora a dancinha